In this problem, we are looking
at a student whose
performance from day to day sort
of oscillates according
to a Markov chain.
In particular, the student can
either be in state 1, which is
a state of being up to date,
or in state 2, which is a
state of being kind
of fallen behind.
Now, the transition
probabilities between these
two states are given by the
numbers here, which is 0.2
from state 1 to 2, 0.6 from 2
to 1, 0.4 from 2 back to 2,
and 0.8 from 1 back
to state 1.
The quantity we're interesting
calculating is this notion of
first passage time.
Let me define what that means.
Suppose we are looking
at a time horizon of
time 0, 1, 2, 3.
And let's call the state of
the Markov chain x of t.
Suppose we start from the chain
being in state 2 here.
Now, if we look at a particular
sample path, let's
say 2 and 2 again on day 1, and
2 again on day 2, and on
day 3, the student
enters state 1.
So in this sample path, we start
from time 0 and time 3
is the first time we
enter state 1.
And we'll say that the first
passage time, namely, the
first time we enter state 1 in
this case, is equal to 3.
More formally, we'll define tj
as the first pass the time to
state 1 conditional on that we
start from state j at time 0.
Now, this quantity, of
course, is random.
Depending on the realization,
we have different numbers.
And we are interested
in calculating the
expected value of t2.
That is, on average, if we start
from state 2 here, how
long would it take for
us to enter state 1?
Now to calculate this quantity,
in the following
recursion will be
very important.
The idea is we don't know
exactly what t2 is.
But t2 has to satisfy a certain
recurrent equation,
namely, t2 must be equal
to 1 plus summation j
equal to 1 to 2 P2jtj.
Now let me explain what
this equation means.
Let's say we are at state 2.
Well, we don't actually know
how long it's going to take
for us to enter state 1.
But we do know after one
step, I will be go
into some other state.
Let's call it state j.
And from state j, it's going
to take some time to enter
state 1 finally.
So this equation essentially
says the time for us to first
enter state 1 from 2 is 1--
which is the next step--
plus the expected time from
that point on to enter 1.
So that constitutes our
[? recurrent ?]
relationship.
Now, by this definition, we can
see that this is simply 1
plus P21 times t1 plus
P22 times t2.
Now, the definition of tj says
t1 must be 0 because, by
definition, if we start
from state 1, we are
already in state 1.
So the time to reach state
1 is simply 0.
So this term disappears.
And we end up with
1 plus P22 t2.
If we plug in a number
of P22--
which is 0.4 right here--
we get 1 plus 0.4 t2.
Now we started from t2 and
we ended up with another
expression involving numbers
and only one
unknown, which is t2.
Combining this together and
solving for t2, we get t2
equals 1 divided by 1 minus
0.4, which is 5/3.
And that is the answer for the
first part of the problem.
In the second part of the
problem, we are asked to do
something similar as before
but with a slight twist.
Here, I copied over the
definition for tj, which is
the first time to visit state
1 starting from state j at
time t equals 0.
And the little tj is
this expectation.
And here we're going to define
a similar quantity, which is
t1, let's say, star, defined
as the first time to visit
state 1 again.
So that's the recurrence part
starting from state 1,
1 at t equals 0.
So this is the recurrence
time from state 1
back to state 1 again.
As an example, again, we look
at t equals 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And here, if we start from state
1 on time 0, we went to
state 2, 2, 1, 1 again.
Now here, again, time 3 will
be the first time to visit
state 1 after time 0.
And we don't count
the very first 0.
And that will be our t1 star.
So t1 star in this particular
case is equal to 3.
OK.
Same as before, we like to
calculate the expected time to
revisit state 1.
Define little t1 star expected
value of t1 star.
And we'll be using the same
recurrence trick through the
following equation.
We say that t1 star is equal
to 1 plus j from 1 to 2.
Now, since we started from state
1, this goes from 1 to
state 1j and tj.
Again, the interpretation is we
started at state 1 at time
t equals 0, we went to
some other state--
we call it j--
and front of state j, it goes
around, and after time
expected value tj, we came
back to state 1.
Here, and as before, this
equation works because we are
working with a Markov chain
whereby the time to reach some
other state only depends
on the current state.
And that's why we're able
to break down the
recursion as follows.
If we write out the recursion,
we get 1 plus
P11 t1 plus P12 t2.
As before, t1 now is just the
expected first passage time
from state 1.
And by definition, it is 0.
Because if we start from state
1, it's already in state 1 and
takes 0 time to get there.
So again, like before,
this term goes out.
And we have 1 plus
0.2 times 5/3.
And this number came from the
previous calculation of t2.
And this gives us 4/3.
So this completes the problem.
And just to remind ourselves,
the kind of crux of the
problem is this type of
recursion which expresses a
certain quantity in the one
incremental step followed by
the expected time to reach
a certain destination
after that one step.
And we can do so because the
dynamics is modeled by a
Markov chain.
And hence, the time to reach a
certain destination after this
first step only depends on where
you start again, in this
case, state j.